last talk so we can um take
a couple of screenshots of all of your
faces
or icons or however you prefer that
would be
wonderful so nikhil whenever you're
ready
so thanks everybody for sticking around
so previously before the break
i showed you this theorem s which is
says if you have a generalized adjacency
matrix for a graph
with a spectral gap and a positive top
eigenvector which cynthia pointed out
then you get this nice diameter bound
and now i'm going to show you how to
apply this to
polytopes so let's go back to setting a
polytope so i have a polytope p
given by some ax less than or equal to b
where none of the constraints are
redundant
and b is positive and
so it has m facets that's equal to the
number of constraints
and it has some n vertices and we don't
know what that is it could be some very
large number
and uh you know two vertices are uh
okay we're interested in this graph gp
which is the adjacency graph of vertices
in this polytope where adjacency means
that they
are the endpoints of an edge in the
polytope
so in order to apply theorem s
we're actually not going to work with p
it's going to be important to work with
the polar of p so recall that if you
have a polytope p
a bounded polytope in rd containing the
origin
it's polar is another polytope in rd
which is actually just the convex hull
of the constraints
appropriately constraint vectors a1
through am appropriately normalized by
the bis which are positive so this makes
sense
so this is another poly to open rd
called p polar
and uh this has very nice properties
so in particular the vertices of the
original polytope correspondent
correspond to facets of the
polar and the vertice sorry the facets
of the original polygon correspond to
vertices of the polar
okay uh yeah yeah
sorry i should have written right so so
the um
uh maybe i should draw right so the
the facets of the original polytope
correspond to
vertices of polar and the vertices of
the original polygon but
correspond to facets of the polar
so the you know maybe a standard example
on the left you have the
l infinity ball the hypercube and rd
which is p
and its polar is just the l1 ball and so
the vertices are these red dots and they
correspond to the
co dimension one facets of people or
on the right hand side and now the nice
thing about the polar is that
adjacency of vertices in p
corresponds to adjacency of facets in p
polar
okay so if your vertices v one through v
n
they correspond to some facets f1
through fn and the point is that two
vertices vi and vj are incident
in the in p in the original polytope if
and only if the corresponding facets
intersect in the polar
so what that means is that this one
skeleton of the original graph is
actually literally equal
to the facet incidence graph of the
polar
so any questions about this
so in particular if i bound the diameter
of the facet incidence graph of polar
i'm happy
right okay so
so this is now our goal right you have p
we pass to p
polar which now is n facets that should
be a capital n
and the goals bound the diameter of the
acid incidence graph of p polar
okay so the key idea in this
is to do something a little that seems a
little
bit not like irrelevant which is to look
at the volume of p polar
okay so this is the key idea so i'm
going to write p
polar as m x less than or equal to c
naught where m is some matrix it's going
to be n
by d so it's not the same as a it's not
the same dimensions as a
and some vector c naught or c naught is
let's say positive
and let's no no redundant constraints
here either so i can
you know i can write p polar in this way
because i can write any bounded ball i
can write any polytope in this way
and now the the key idea is to consider
the volume of p polar
as a function of the slack vector c
okay so this is defined by a bunch of
linear inequalities where the right hand
side is given by c
naught i'm now going to treat that c
naught as a variable
and look at p polar of c which is going
to be
now a polytope where the right hand side
is replaced by the vector c
so that's a bounded polytope um that has
some volume
and so i'm going to define this function
v of c volume of p polar c
it's well defined in a neighborhood of c
naught
it may not be defined everywhere because
you know you could
well i mean you could just get well okay
it would be
it could be defined anywhere you might
get something empty
but let's just look at a neighborhood of
c naught
okay so any questions about the
definition of this function
okay okay so this function has two
nice properties which are both classical
maybe known for close to 100 years
let me tell you what they are so these
properties require a non-degeneracy
assumption which is that people are
simple which we'll remove later so don't
worry about it that's a technical
assumption if you know what it is
so if people are simple then it turns
out this function is differentiable
it's actually twice differentiable this
volume function at least locally
and the first claim is that the hessian
of this function
is a generalized adjacency matrix of the
skeleton
of the of the polytope of the
of pe which is the facet incidence graph
of the polytone
okay so this makes sense right because p
polar has
n facets which is the same as a number
of vertices of p
now this function is a function of n
variables right because for each facet i
can change the slack in that facet
and so the hessian is an n by n matrix
indexed by the facets of p polar
and so this statement at least makes
sense the hessian of
v is a generalized adjacency matrix of p
of gp which is the faster incidence
graph of people
i'll prove this to the next slide but
any questions about the statement
okay so this is like a you know
combinatorial property of the hessian
saying that the non the pattern of
non-zeros in the hessian
is related to the underlying
combinatorics
this i guess goes back to at least
alexandra but maybe more i mean
you'll see it's very easy the second
claim is an analytic claim
which is that this hatching has exactly
one positive eigenvalue
okay so it's a symmetric matrix we're
claiming that it has exactly one
positive eigenvalue
this also goes back to at least
alexandrov
so i'll prove these in a moment but any
questions about these claims
so not a question about the claim but i
think i'm like a little lost about
how you defined v of c like
e zero right so so v of c
zero is the volume of p polar
so what i'm doing is i'm going to
replace the c naught by a
variable c right and as i change c i get
different polytopes right
and each of them has a volume so that
defines a function
does that answer the question and then
when you take the hessian
of this function yeah you take the
hessian of that function v
so so va is a function right v
is a function from r and
okay i didn't define it everywhere but
sure i can define it everywhere from rn
to r
right because for every c i put in there
i get a polytope and it has a volume
i mean okay i don't want to define all
of our end cause the volume could be
infinity but
but volume is continuous and in a
neighborhood of this c naught
these will always these will be finite
so this is a well-defined function in a
neighborhood of xenon
okay i see it makes sense and then i can
take derivatives right
any other question
so the hessian should have all
non-negative entries right
uh uh well
you mean in order to apply theorem s
yeah that's one thing
uh well i guess like my intuition is
like you increase
c well monetary to entry to introduce c
at the same time
there's like like uh i don't know it's
like the alexander
kind of argument yeah where like you add
a square term
in the volume right your intuition is
absolutely correct all the off-diagonal
entries are non-negative
as we'll see on the next slide then the
diagonal entries are negative
but yeah okay yeah yeah yeah yeah i was
thinking off diagonal yeah
you're right so so let's now see this
so claim one this is a generalization
matrix so let's just compute the
derivatives right
so let's draw two facets f i and f j of
b polar
and let's perturb the ith slack
entry right ci when that happens
that facet is going to move a little bit
and it's easier to see the change in
volume is going to be
the well d minus one dimensional volume
of that facet
okay from this picture right if you
slide the
the uh if constraint a little bit
then you're gonna you know move parallel
to the facet
fi and the change in volume is going to
be proportional to the
you know area of that facet which is
i've written as absolute value of f i
so the first derivative is kind of clear
and now if you want to calculate the
second derivative you need to do a
little trigonometry
but i mean i won't go through it here
but it's a sort of trigonometric
exercise that now your interest
the second derivative the partial i
partial j is asking
how much does the area of f i
change when i move f j right that's what
it's asking
so the angle is obviously going to play
a role and if you just work this out you
get that it's this
it's the d minus two dimensional volume
of the intersection
f intersect fj times cosecant of this
angle
and by the way this angle is not zero
because there are no redundant
constraints
so you know i won't do the trigonometry
but the point is this is not zero if and
only if two facets are adjacent and
indeed this is positive as greg
said for json facets so that's the proof
of claim one it's
just calculus
any questions about that
okay proof of claim 2
that the hessian has exactly one
positive eigenvalue
this follows from the broom minkowski
inequality so
this function c goes to log of the
volume of c
so you cannot take the log right because
the volume is positive
at least in a neighborhood of c naught
it's a fact from convex geometry that
this is a concave function
okay so this is equivalent essenti this
is essentially follows from or
equivalent to the broom minkowski
inequality which says that log of volume
is concave under minkowski addition
i'm not claiming this is obvious but
it's a classical inequality
and analysis and a different phrasing of
it
i mean okay what's written in the
parentheses is literally the same after
exponentiating
but you may be more familiar with that
version of the brunemenkowski inequality
for polytopes okay so this is an
analytic property of this function that
its log is concave
but now okay i mean okay this means that
the hessian of the log of v
is not negative semi-definite and then
by calculus
which is just a general fact about
functions the hessian of the function
itself has one positive eigenvalue
so the this therefore stuff at the
bottom is just this just you know chain
rule or whatever
but you know the point is it's a concave
function
so any any questions about that
okay now it sounds like we're heading in
the right direction right we have a
generalized adjacency matrix
we know something about its eigenvalues
namely that exactly one of them is
positive
but really we need a spectral gap right
we need a quantitative bound so how do
we do that
so that will be claim three which is
just a little observation
the observation is that this hessian if
you actually calculate it has
an additional useful structure which is
it's equal to negative a graph laplacian
plus a diagonal matrix
okay if you know what a graph laplacian
is it's a special kind of adjacency
matrix of a graph
and the important property of a graph
laplacian is a graph of question is
positive semi-refined
okay so if you just write out what the
entries of the session are you will
observe
that it's equal to negative a graph of a
position plus a positive diagonal matrix
so this is sometimes called a
schrodinger operator in i guess
physics
now once you have this you can it's kind
of nice because you can
you can turn a qualitative statement
about one positive eigenvalue
into a quantitative statement about
spectral gap by doing the following
consider the matrix d to the minus half
hd to the minus half where h
is the hessian so you rescale the matrix
by the
inverse square root of this diagonal
matrix on both sides
so we can do that right the equation in
claim 3 if we rescale by d to the minus
half of
both sides you get that this rescale
matrix is minus d to the
minus half l d minus half plus identity
okay so now we're happy right because
the matrix on the left hand side has one
positive eigenvalue by sylvester's law
of inertia
you didn't change the signature by
multiplying on the left and right
by diagonal matrix like that but the
same argument
the first term on the right hand side is
negative semi-definite by sylvester's
law of inertia because the laplacian is
positive semi-definite it's a minus
silver flash and it's negative
semi-definite
and so when you scale it that doesn't
change so you have a matrix
with one positive eigenvalue equal to a
negative semi-definite matrix plus
identity
so the only way that's possible is that
the top eigenvalue is equal to one
and so we can conclude that this scaled
matrix has a spectral gap of one
okay this is not a deep thing but
the structure schrodinger's structure is
important to be able to do this
so any questions about this
okay so we're almost getting there to be
able to apply theorem s but we're not
done because this thing has a spectral
gap but we don't know where all the
other eigen values are right they could
be all over the place they could be very
negative they could be whatever right
so really the punch line is that after
doing some calculations and some matrix
analysis you see that a certain affine
scaling of this matrix actually has all
the properties you need for theorem s
okay it's a adjacency matrix of the
graph
it has a strictly positive eigenvector
which we saw
in the last part is required it has a
spectral gap of gamma and all the other
eigenvalues are contained in the unit
interval
and this gamma that you get after you do
these calculations which i'm skipping
are that the spectral gap is equal to
sine squared of the minimum angle
between facets of the polar
so it's a measure of non-degeneracy
right so if you go back to
this picture in this little proof here i
had these angles theta i j right
and as the follow type is getting
degenerate they're getting very close to
zero
so when the dust settles when the dust
settles when you do
all this stuff you get that the spectral
gap is the sine squared of that angle
so it's some measure of degeneracy of
the polytope
and now you can apply the theorem right
you have you have a adjacency matrix of
the graph you care about
it has a spectral gap the eigenvector is
positive
and so you get this bound the diameter
is bounded by log n plus 2 log 1 over v
min over sine theta
and then you have to do some more work
to relate this theta min
and v min to the integer entries
appearing in the matrix which i'm
suppressing because it's just a bunch of
calculations
but the point is that you can control
both the angle between facets of the
polar
and the entries of the top eigenvector
of this matrix which are positive you
can control their magnitude
using this fact about the integer-ness
of the matrix
right so you can prove that i mean
because they're integers these things
can't be zero
and there's some bound on how small they
can be and you just calculate that bound
and then you get the result
and okay final green parentheses i
assumed all this stuff i assume the
polytop was simple
you know even in defining the hessian
you can remove this assumption
by an approximation argument which is
due to ismet cf from 2010.
so the simplicity does not pose any
serious concern
so that is the proof of the theorem this
is a
summary of what happened right you pass
from p to p
polar you look at log of volume i guess
its volume of
you know volume of water it's the volume
of p polar of c as a function of the
slacks right
just to remind you and the analytic
factor that that's concave that tells
you that the hessian has one positive
eigenvalue
which then because of the schrodinger
structure tells you that a certain
scaling has a spectral gap
which then by you know this is where you
apply theorem s
and you apply this stuff about knowing
the integer entries you get that the
skeleton small diameter
so that's an outline of the proof and
the goal was to just present this idea
of using
lock concavity to get a spectral gap in
the paper
we use this to prove
you know something a little more
intricate which is
oh which is not on the slides but well
okay we analyze what happens for random
polytopes and
prove that their skeletal which are
random graphs have a giant component of
polynomial diameter if
that is interesting to you but i guess
the point is that this idea can be used
to prove
you know more other statements beyond
just this
integer polyatom small diameter so
that's a summary and here are some
open questions so one is can you prove
the polynomial horse conjecture for
random polytopes
using this technique or otherwise i mean
using whatever technique you want
another question is
can you analyze a natural random walk on
the vertices of the polytope
using um so in this stock we use
continuous log concavity which is
literally lock and cavity of the volume
but there's this very important work of
an aria of s current lou and vincent
where they they analyzed random walks on
metroids
using a certain notion of discrete log
concavity so one speculative question is
can you use
techniques like that to analyze any
random walk on the vertices of a
polytope
it's not too far-fetched but we weren't
able to figure it out
and a final very speculative comment is
that this one positive eigenvalue
is part of something called the hajj
riemann relations
associated with some graded algebra
associated with polytope
and speculative question are the other
ones useful for
doing combinatorics of this sort so
so that's it and i don't know why my
video stopped working uh
but yeah
let's all thank nikhil some
clap emojis
um and we have quite a bit of time for
questions
so if anyone has any questions um the
recording is off now
so